[Music]
Hi, Mataz here. Today we're going to
look at how to record, edit, and mix
your guitars in Bitwig Studio. Now, this
is going to be a very beginner friendly
tutorial. So, strap on those headphones
and let's take the tour. Okay, so we're
here in Bitwig 6. This is actually the
beta 2 version, but don't worry, all
these things we talk about today will
work in a previous Bitwig version, too.
So, let's begin creating a few tracks.
So, we're going to hold the command,
shift, and press T to add new audio
track. If you only hold command and
press T, you're going to add in the
instrument track. So hold command,
shift, and T. So now we have two tracks.
And let's first rename this to acoustic
guitar. So we're going to hold command R
and right. Acoustic left and rename the
second one to acoustic
right. First out, you obviously want to
make sure that you have the correct
inputs available in Bitwig. So go to
your dashboard, go to settings and audio
and make sure you have your selected
proper audio device. Mine is the Centur
from Antelope Audio and we can select
the sample rate to 48 kHz. And uh we're
going to make sure we have a pretty low
block size sample rate so we have the
lowest amount of latency. And below that
we will see our available inputs and
outputs. Next up we're going to select
the inputs for the track. So, select the
first track, go to your inspector panel
off to the left, and um open the inputs
panel and go to audio inputs, and we're
going to set the monoponic input to one.
My microphone for this example sits
above. That's because I don't want to
have it um covering the image, but
usually you want to have it like 15 cm
or 12 cm from the 12th fret pointing
towards the hole of your guitar.
Right? Right. So, we have the input set
for our first track. Let's go to the
second track and also select the
monophonic input one. Now, to activate
record in Bitwig, we can either activate
the record button like this and press
play or press play and then activate
record. But, uh I usually set a key
command to activate record. Now, by
default, I think toggle record is the
F9. But uh since we often use the R key
in other doors, we probably should set
up that in Bitwig 2. So you go into the
dashboard, go to the shortcuts in the
settings, and you can search for record.
And there we have a toggle record. So
just delete the previous shortcut, press
the plus key, and
select the R key and press add. And now
we can toggle the recorder with the R
key. Nice and sweet. Hm. I actually
think that we should change the BPM to
128. So, make a double click over the
BPM and enter 128.
Now, we're going to make sure our
playhead is in the beginning. That's
this blue little arrow. So, set it to
the beginning of your arrangement. and
press RM space.
[Music]
So, that's our first acoustic guitar
track. And we're going to pan that all
to the left. And we're going to pan our
second guitar the right. And we can do
that in the inspector panel too, like
so.
So, let's activate record again and
press space.
[Music]
Nice. Let's um zoom out a little bit
here. You can always hover above the
timeline and drag downwards and upwards
to zoom in and out of your arrangement.
Now, don't worry if the volume sounds
low at this point.
Okay. So, let's trim the endings of
these clips. We hover above the top
right side of our clips and just drag it
so it matches with the bars. So, we have
the exact bars. Now, if you want to
balance these tracks against each other,
we can always open the mixer. And you do
that by pressing the tab key or below
here, you can change between arrange and
mix and edit.
Now, if you want to know the peak levels
of the tracks, you can just look at the
bottom section of the tracks. And we can
see that the left uh guitar peaks at -14
dB and the right is peing at minus1 12
dB. But uh you can always reset this by
just pressing above and press play again
to get the new reading of the peaks.
Now don't worry if the volume sounds low
here. We can always fix that later. It's
better to be a little bit low and just
increase the headphones uh volume or the
volume of your speakers. Right. So, next
up, we're going to do some processing.
So, on this first track, let's press the
D key to open the devices panel. Now,
that's where you add the different
plugins like EQs, compression, and uh
distortion and reverbs and delays and
stuff. First up, we're going to press
the plus sign and we're going to add an
equalizer. So, let's add the EQ5,
which is a five band equalizer. And if
you want a larger overview of the
equalizer, you can always press this
show expanded device view.
Now, we can sweep the frequency spectrum
to find out where we have annoying
frequencies and just reduce this
[Music]
Just make a little dip here at 300 300
htz and uh make a bump here later on in
the high frequency area around 8k
something so we get more of that uh
bright sound of the strings.
And we can always add a highp pass
filter to get rid of the low-end rumble
around 60 70 Hz or something.
One of the really sweet devices to
process guitars is uh the multi effect
device which is basically a multiband
compressor and can also be multiband
saturation. So we're going to press the
plus sign after our equalizer and add a
second plugin. So, search for multi
and we're going to add a multiband
effects three. Now, if you want to see
the different presets available for this
device, you can always press this little
arrow to the right side of the browser.
So, we're going to add a
multi-distortion. And you can always uh
audition the effects while you're
browsing.
So, let's add a multi-distortion. And
we're going to solo this one and just uh
make it center when we're processing.
[Music]
So you can hear we instantly get the
more upfront sound from the multiband
effects here.
[Music]
Going to drive that pretty hard.
Now, if you want to copy these settings
to the second acoustic guitar track, it
can be suitable to put all these devices
in a chain device, which is like a
container for different plugins. So,
prior to the equalizer, we're going to
press the plus sign and add
for Shane. And we're going to add that
Shane device. And then we can just drag
the equalizer and drag that multi-band
effects into the chain.
So now they're contained as you can see
with this blue line which shows all the
devices that's contained within the
parent device. So these are basically
childs to our parent chain device. And
then we can just copy this chain device
by holding alt and drag that to the
second track. So now we have the same
kind of processing for both of these
tracks.
[Music]
Okay. So, now let's record a melodic
layer. So, press command, shift, and t
and add a third acoustic guitar track.
And we're going to press command R and
rename that to melody one. And let's
record some kind of melody on top of
this. maybe record something like
And before we record, we're going to
make sure that we're recording the
correct audio input, the mono input,
because by default, it's set to the
stereo input.
Okay, so let's press R and space.
[Music]
[Applause]
And let's trim the ending again. Trim
that to the same length.
And let's copy the chain again to this
track so we get a little bit boost in
volume.
Now we're going to enter the chain and
uh add some additional effects on the
melody track.
Maybe add some more compression after
the equalizer. Press the plus sign
between the equalizer and the multiband.
And we can search for compressor or comp
and add the compressor plus. Now you can
also work with the com regular
compressor device or the dynamics
device. But let's h use the compressor
plus. And we're going to increase the
auto timing. So we have a automatic uh
settings for the attack and release
and we can drag the threshold just so we
hit the spikes of the trans.
We can press the L to learn which means
that we're going to learn how much
compensation we need to do with the
gain. But I usually add a little bit.
Now I'm changing the compressor mode
from clear to saturate, which is going
to give us a more analog tape-l like
feel to the compression. As you can
hear, it's quite nice.
So, we can also make a double click on
these devices to make them more narrow
so they don't take up too much space.
And we can press the plus sign and add
the delay plus.
And we're going to make it a ping pong
delay. And just reduce the frequency so
we get a more narrow frequency on the
delay taps. And maybe also change the
software to space, which is going to
give us a little bit of reverb or a long
reverb tail on on the delay taps.
[Music]
You can get really sweet effects if you
freeze the delay. Plus, as you can hear.
[Music]
Yeah, but that's a story.
Let's unfreeze that and let's take a
listen in context.
[Music]
Let's reduce the spaces just a little
bit so we get a more clear tone from the
melody.
Next up, we're going to duplicate that
melody track and duplicate it with a
higher pitched melody. Press command D
to duplicate the track. Oops. And then
we can always just delete the content
and record a new melody. So, let's
record.
[Music]
And again, we're going to trim the
ending. Maybe also recolor this track.
Always fun to have different colors on
all the tracks. If you want to resize
all the tracks, we can always hover
above the lower side of the track and
press the shift and drag upwards and all
the tracks will be compressed in height
or expanded in height if you want.
[Music]
[Applause]
If you want to add fades either in or
out of this uh audio readers, you can
just hover above the left side or right
side like this and just drag into the
track like this or at the end of the
track. And you get the sweet fade.
[Music]
Right. That's basically how you prepare
and set up for recording in Bitwig
Studio and also make some quick editing
and uh processing and mixing of the
tracks. Now, if you have any type of
questions regarding audio editing,
mixing or processing in Bitwig Studio,
let me know here in the comments. Now,
if you want to learn more, make sure to
check out my Bitwig Studio Masterass and
also my Bitwig ambient master course if
you want to learn how to create the
ambient music in Bitwig Studio. Okay,
make sure to subscribe. I'm Matias. See
you in the next episode. Bye.